[Musique]
général benny je me tourne vers vous
pour les gens qui nous regardent en ce
moment on imagine que cette cérémonie
elle est d'abord très codifié d'un point
de vue militaire entre les uniformes
portés par ceux qui portent les
cercueils par exemple la présence des
drapeaux sur les cercueils les uniformes
que l'on voit est ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer un petit peu de quoi il
en retourne oui je dirais d'abord que
les gens qui portent le cercueil
appartiennent à l'unité est très
certainement été choisi parce qu'il y
avait un lien de de fonctionnel et de
camaraderie avec le camarade disparu
ce qui veut dire que vous avez là des
des garçons qui sont certainement très
ému ensuite c'est techniquement pas
facile de porter un cercueil j'ai
malheureusement eu à le faire en montant
ensuite un crash de nora cloche à
djibouti les les sentiments qui peuvent
animer ces garçons ce sont son sang sont
bien sûr de la peine et je pense surtout
la volonté de montrer de mettre un peu
en spectacle pour eux mêmes pour leurs
camarades pour les familles la réalité
du combat qui a été celui de leurs
camarades
je crois que c'est il faut voir ça d'une
manière positive nous avons marque sur
lefigaro.fr pardonnez moi de vous
interrompre les soldats qui porte les
cercueils sont ils leurs camarades
oui bien évidemment donc ils les ont
côtoyés très certainement
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que représente
d'ailleurs une une cérémonie comme celle
ci
la mort de leur camarade est ce que les
soldats ils sont préparés
psychologiquement moralement comment
affronte il ce choc
personnellement à côté lorsqu'il s'agit
de la vie de la mort de la vie et de la
mort de proches
il ya quand même déjà un domaine
personnel qui est liée aux liens que
vous pouvez avoir tissé avec les
camarades disparus
et hier c'est un domaine qui appartient
à chacun maintenant ce qui est du
ressort de la de la militarité à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés là c'est
que il ya un esprit de corps ce sont des
gens qui se sont entraînés ensemble ce
sont des gens qui ont passé les mêmes
épreuves les mêmes certificat militaires
les mêmes brevets de pilote s'il s'agit
des camarades de la latte qui ont fait
des courses en montagne en soit enfin
ils ont un vécu ils ont ils ont beaucoup
de beaucoup de souvenirs en commun et
j'imagine que tout ça doit en quelque
sorte défilé dans la tête de ceux qui
portent ces cercueils
c'était un moment mais je répète qu'il
faut considérer de façon positive parce
que vous rend hommage
on montre que c'est un métier
particulier et qui doit continuer de
l'être et il est très bien qu'il y ait
ce moment de comment dire d'unités de
national
autant que faire se peut pour ce strict
au moment du deuil après les évolutions
politiques etc
vous évoquez tout à l'heure c'est un
autre domaine je crois qu'il ya le temps
du deuil
le temps des hommages et puis business
as usual reprendra après dans quelques
minutes maintenant le président de la
république emmanuel macron prendra à
prendre la parole pour l'éloge funèbre
il ne s'exprimera pas a priori sur les
modalités d'action de la force par canot
au sahel et qu'il a déclaré jeudi
dernier vouloir réexaminer
il s'exprimera sur la condition des
soldats les raisons de leur combat et la
notion d'héroïsme
en tout cas c'est ce que faisait savoir
le communiqué de l'elysée
françois-xavier bourmaud bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur le
plateau de figaro live pour cet hommage
je rappelle que vous êtes grand reporter
au service politique du figaro
l'éloge funèbre c'est un exercice
difficile et forcément empreint
d'émotion mais c'est aussi un exercice
politique on peut le dire
pour le chef de l'état il est essentiel
de démontrer que ces hommes morts ne
sont pas que des victimes et qui sont
des héros c'est la huitième fois depuis
le début de son mandat qui mêle macron
se retrouve aux invalides il faut bien
préciser que cette cérémonie le fait
qu'elle se déroule aux invalides c'est
une décision du président de la
république c'est lui qui choisi
d'organiser cet hommage à cet endroit là
parce que ça s'inscrit dans un discours
qu'il déploie depuis son élection qui
vise à revaloriser l'héroïsme français à
valoriser le le héros français
il est vraisemblable que dans son
discours il va il va en parler de ces
soldats qui ont payé de leur vie leur
engagement pour pour la nation il s'agit
pour le président de la république pour
emmanuel macron de diriger en modèle
d'engagement c'est ces soldats qui sont
morts sur le sur le terrain pour
à peu redonné une du corps au récit
français il d'aider le mois de d'août
2010 est certes très peu de temps après
son élection et donne une interview dans
le point dans laquelle il explique
justement que les jeunes générations ont
pour modèles souvent des et des
footballeurs des des chanteurs mais ont
perdu de vue
c'est cet aspect d'engagement national
il est vraisemblable que dans son
discours il insiste beaucoup sur ce
point la liberté mais je me tourne vers
vous avant de vous libérer je crois vous
avez des impératifs devait nous quitter
rapidement la mort de ses 13 hommes au
combat risque-t-elle de précipiter le
débat sur le rôle de l'armée française
de l'action militaire française au sahel
papa papa précisément d'abord parce que
ce sont comme on l'a dit ce sont des
morts dans un accident alors même si un
accident en opération ça n'a rien à voir
par exemple ce qui s'était passé à ousse
b en afghanistan on a eu des morts au
combat on devrait repenser la stratégie
en fonction je vais pas sous le contrôle
du général je suis pas militaire mais
d'un point de vue politique si vous
voulez ça n'impose en revanche ce qui
peut poser des questions c'est que on
l'a dit déjà
cette opération dure maintenant depuis
longtemps elle va durer encore longtemps
alors oui il faut évidemment repenser
l'opération mais il faut repenser
n'importe quel militaire vous le dira
ces plans dont les repenser en
permanence est toujours en retrait n'est
pas une réalité
je ne pense pas qu actuellement un
retrait soit envisagée ça serait ça
serait un échec terrible pour la france
d'un point de vue militaire et d'un
point de vue diplomatique donc ça je ne
pense pas que ce sera possible de
compléter ce que j'ai compris qu'à un
moment vous avez dit que les plans ils
sont toujours remis en cause et c'est à
moi j'ai appartenu au centre de
planification et de conduite des
opérations pendant quatre ans il
faudrait pas laisser croire aux gens qui
nous regardent qu'eux ont dit qu'un on a
treize morts qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe bien
évidemment en permanence et vous l'avez
dit en permanence ou
on suit la situation et il ya un bureau
qui s'appelle le bureau plan qui est un
prestigieux l'état-major dans lesquels
on est sans arrêt en train de tirer des
enseignements de ce qui est en train de
se passer et de voir par rapport aux
lignes d'opérations théorique où on se
situe et quel est le meilleur moyen de
revenir sur le ce qui était prévu ou
bien de modifier ce qui était prévu en
fonction des réalités du terrain donc
vous avez parfaitement raison
on va pas faire des grandes remises en
cause suite à cet accident là mais parce
que c'est le cours normal d'une
opération que de se remettre en question
à certaines étapes je vous faire perdre
de nouveau merci d'ailleurs à tous ceux
qui nous suivent en direct que de
partager votre émotion devant cette
cérémonie en hommage aux treize soldats
morts en opérations au mali
vous avez communiqué par facebook
énormément par exemple jeanne nous dit
que la cérémonie est très émouvante
martin penser à toutes les familles
endeuillées
robert sur facebook ajoute ces images
sont très dures paix aux âmes des
disparus et courage aux familles
merci à viviane pour son témoignage il
est triste de voir tous ces jeunes
soldats morts qu'il repose en paix